Let's go to the phones.
(617) 830-4750 is the number.
Let's start with our caller today from the
48 four area code.
Who's calling today from four eight four
is that mean?
That is you.
Who is this?
Hi, my name is Louis.
I'm from Delaware.
Hey Louis.
What's going on?
Okay.
Hi there.
Um, first of all, I just want to say congratulations
on a such a such a great show.
I love listening to your, to your, I'm very
level headed, um, outtake because sometimes
I'll watch ring of fire and it Kinda gets
me angry in the morning, so I have to stop
for a sec.
Well, that's because barren is genuinely so
angry about the injustices that are going
on that he gets angry and then it angers the
audience and then everybody ends up very angry.
But he does a good job, I think.
Yeah, I, he does and I'm, I do like him and
like Pat Antonio has taco over at the port,
but um, I guess gets my main questions since,
uh, times of the essence.
Um, I have a lot of trouble talking with all
my friends.
They're all housed.
They were all gamers.
Um, of course I know, I know you're not familiar
with what's going on with there, but um, there's
been a lot of backlash with like, um, virtual
signaling and um, basically everybody is just
like hounding on cyber punks like portrayal
even though it's supposed to be dystopia and
now what's, what's Louis, what's virtual signaling?
Well that's what they tell me that say that
like I'm saying that like a lot of these mainstream
um, outlets are saying are calling it distasteful.
Like, you know, you should have portrayed,
you know, a non white male all the time.
And it's really, I mean for me it's not a
problem because for me, I like, I understand
that it's them trying to get outraged clicks,
but it's making all my friends basically start
saying like, this is the left is the left
is less fault and it's hard for me to tell
them like this is neoliberalism.
Basically it's,
but hold on this, hold on.
We're getting very much this virtual signaling
that you're referring to, which big media
outlets are doing it.
Um, so it's more of like the gaming a major
amount.
It's like the talk.
Who um, who else is there?
There's rock rock, paper, shotgun.
Um, let's see.
Polygon.
Like a lot of people hate them.
I'll be honest, Lewis, I don't know anything
about this and I'm the last person who could
comment on it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, well I guess I should get your advice
then.
Like how should I tell them that this is more
of like a corporate sort of speak rather than
like actual like what really what the left
is about.
Even though like socially, yes, they say you
know, are all pro LGBTQ and all that.
But like in the essence it's profit in the
end.
Yes.
Right.
I mean, listen to this, this is not unique
to the gaming industry.
You just, you just got to point out companies
might have an internal culture that is or
seems progressive or left wing, but that in
the end, uh, having policies of treating transgender
people correctly, uh, might only seem like
it's progressive right now.
But actually it's just the way things are
going.
We treat everybody with respect and that the
idea that that makes a company left wing,
you've got to look at sort of the, the how
they are positioned within the corporate space.
And ultimately what you will usually arrive
at is the reality that these are profit oriented
companies.
That's the number one priority above all else.
If being LGBTQ friendly is a path towards
that, then they'll do it.
Yes, yes, of course.
So it's very difficult for me to communicate
that to them because you know, because they
always think that all these developers have
their, have a gun to their heads and that
they must do this and that to pander to, to
minorities all the time.
I'm sitting like it's, it's not affecting
the gaming and it, well, it, it's, it's to
a point where it is actually a factor.
I got to Lewis.
Listen, I really don't know much else about
it, so I'm going to let you go because I've
got 52 people holding, but I appreciate the
call and I hope to hear from you very, very
soon.